première mondiale au royaume uni où on
vient d'autoriser une étude de
provocation qui va infecter
intentionnellement des volontaires avec
le virus de lakovic 19
ces travaux pourraient permettre de
répondre à des questions importantes
notamment sur les effets des différentes
variantes du virus dont on a encore
beaucoup parlé cette semaine mais cela
soulève aussi des interrogations
éthiques
ce genre d'étude qu'on appelle aussi
charles lynch dadis ne date pas d'hier
elle consiste à infectés délibérément
des volontaires avec un pathogène pour
étudier les effets d'un traitement ou
d'un vaccin
une équipe de nîmes puis au collège de
londres va donc recruter 90 volontaires
en bonne santé âgés de 18 à 30 ans pour
les infectés avec le virus sera ce
costume dans un premier temps
différentes doses du virus sont
vaporisées d'emmener des participants
qui sont ensuite isolés sous étroite
surveillance
le but c'est déterminer quelle quantité
de virus suffit à provoquer la maladie
on veut aussi étudier la réponse
immunitaire des volontaires et comment
il relâche le virus dans leur
environnement
les participants affecté recevront
rapidement un médicament leur md et vire
c'est un antiviral qui a montré des
résultats mitigés
j'ai des patients hospitalisés pour la
coved 19 mai certaines études laissent
croire qu'il pourrait être plus efficace
si des données plus tôt le virus utilisé
sera celui qui circulait au royaume uni
l'été dernier
plus tard les chercheurs pourraient
utiliser et nouveau variant du virus
comme celui qui a été découvert dans le
pays à l'automne si tout ce passe bien
les espère mener des essais de
provocation pour tester des nouveaux
vaccins
ça permettrait de vérifier leur
efficacité sur quelques centaines de
personnes plutôt que des dizaines de
milliers comme cela se fait dans les
essais cliniques classique
ce serait moins coûteux et surtout moins
long avant d'avoir des résultats
mais c'est loin de faire l'unanimité on
parle d'ailleurs décès de provocations
depuis le début de la pandémie et c'est
seulement maintenant que le premier est
autorisée
la principale crainte de ceux qui s'y
opposent c'est la sécurité
on a beau choisir des volontaires jeunes
et en santé le risque existe qu'il
puisse tomber sévèrement malades ou même
mourir de la copine
le fait est qu'on a aucun traitement
pour
les manades on sait aussi maintenant que
beaucoup de chats garde des séquelles à
plus ou moins long terme de la maladie y
compris des patients jeunes ou qui ont
été peu malade pendant l'infection
malgré cela les chercheurs britanniques
ne devraient pas avoir trop de mal à
trouver des volontaires sur ce site
dédié
des milliers de personnes ont déjà
manifesté leur intérêt
[Musique]